see my slides and hear me
i um i can hear you but not your screen
i can't see the screen
okay um i'll take the majority vote in
that case
uh uh so this is work i'll be talking
about that's
joint work with uh georg strasti and
andre barretto
and what i'm really going to focus on is
one particular way of doing
exploration with options uh which we're
just calling temporally extended epsilon
greedy
because of its uh similarity to the
strategy for epsilon greedy
um in addition to kind of this
general strategy where if you have
options here's one way to explore with
them we also
are going to also talk about a very
simple
choice of those options which is more of
a heuristic choice of those options
and show that it's actually a
surprisingly strong
baseline to be considering when we look
at this type of exploration
but before i really get into the meat of
the the presentation i want to
talk a little bit about uh how we
actually go about understanding our
exploration algorithms and this
i think has some similarities with some
of the points that ian was making in the
first talk
so on on the one hand we could take a
very empirical approach
and try to evaluate a new method or an
existing method
on some set of domains that we think of
as representative of the types of
problems we care about
there's actually some overlap here with
chelsea's talk too
and hope that this performance will
carry over
to the larger class of problems that if
it works well in these it'll work well
in those as well
but for this to work as a principled
approach we really need to keep that
representative set
large and diverse in the ways that we
expect the real
set of problems to mirror otherwise
as a as a researcher or as a field we
might tend to overfit
on a limited set of problems
alternatively or
you know in addition to that we can also
try to
analyze our algorithms theoretically
and you know at least this might tell us
some guarantees about
asymptotic performance as an example but
the other really
great benefit from that type of work is
that it can give us and i think ian did
say this but it can give us
intuition into where we think
a a particular algorithm will work well
or
poorly and i think that that's
particularly important when we're
kind of throwing away all of the
guarantees we get from those small
uh types of mdps finite state mdps and
that we can understand them really well
that we can carry that intuition over
into the larger scale problems
so turning to that empirical evaluation
side
it this set of atari games at least in
the discrete action
case often ends up becoming the
representative set
of problems for exploration or maybe
even worse
we end up narrowing that just to the one
in the far left and focus only on
montezuma's revenge
and that could lead to that type of
overfitting
problem in fact i think a great uh
piece of evidence and that direction
comes from a paper published at iclear
this year
and what they did is they re-implemented
a variety of different intrinsic
motivation-based algorithms
all using the same agent architecture
and evaluated them on some of the atari
57 games
and one of the there's two really
interesting things here at least but uh
one of the first ones is that in that
reimplementation and comparison a lot of
these different methods that had
vastly different scores in the published
results end up performing very very
similarly on montezuma's revenge and
this seems to suggest that
they're not complete the results that
they've seen
previously don't don't carry over to
different agent architectures if there
was something specific about that
agent architecture or training uh regime
that allowed it to do especially well in
those
those works the other really interesting
thing here
is the evidence that we might have been
overfitting to montezuma's revenge
which can be seen in the two plots in
the center and the right
where the order of which algorithm is
preferable
changes significantly depending on the
game even
worse often they get outperformed by
epsilon greedy itself
and and this says that they're not
capturing
um at at least our intuitive
understanding of
strong broadly applicable exploration
but seem to be focused
at doing very well at montezuma's
revenge perhaps at the expense
of many other at least games in the
atari suite
i think so just to to reference forward
a little bit
i'll i'll be showing some evaluation
results on the on the full suite of
atari 57 and i think this
immediately jumps out that there is some
overfitting happening
in the algorithm design but that said
i don't think atari is enough for a
representative sample for our empirical
validation
on the analytical side it doesn't really
get any nicer
um because let's consider these three uh
exploration algorithms that i'm using
because i'm going to compare against
them later on
there's nothing particularly hard to
understand about them
as as as examples but they are
nonetheless it's very hard to get that
intuition we want out just thinking
about the algorithm itself
and what it might imply about the type
of mdps where they're going to work well
now i think uh b suite is a nice example
where you can
kind of split the difference between the
theoretical analysis and the
empirical by likes doing this kind of
soft theory that b suite kind of allows
you to do to get back at that intuition
but one of the nice things about
exploring with options is because
the exploration let's say priors are
encoded by the behaviors of these
options
and what we care about is how well those
behaviors lead us to cover
the reachable states it's a little bit
easier to pull in some
intuition as to what types of problems a
particular let's say
set of options or optimization target
for those options
is going to work well in so the the
general uh topic here is temporally
extended epsilon greedy
and it's exactly what it sounds like
we're going to essentially do epsilon
greedy exploration
where at each step we're going to act
greedily with probability one minus
epsilon
but instead of taking a random action
we're going to draw a random option
from this set of options from some
sampling distribution
over them and then execute the option
policy
until it terminates and that gives us
the temporal persistence
and and the the two questions that we
need to ask to tell whether or not
this actually makes any sense or not is
uh what is that set of
options or where do we get them and how
do we sample from them
so if we want to learn this set of
options directly from the experience
within this domain there are a lot of
previous works that focus on this type
of problem learning
learning options specifically for
exploration or
learning uh may be framed not as options
but as
skills uh that diversely cover the set
of possible states
and maybe to call out two kind of
groupings here you could imagine
one grouping such as the things like
eigen options or
or the cover options where we're adding
options to this set of options
specifically to
optimize our ability to quickly cover
the vast majority of the states to
look at ways to change the transition
diagrams between states by adding an
option
and that's very appealing because of it
it directly optimizing for the thing we
would care about
um and on the other side of things
things like uh diversity is all you need
or the dynamics aware
discovery of skills where you're looking
instead at
creating this i would call them set of
options but again call different things
by different people
that are trying to ensure that you have
this diversity of differences in your
behaviors
so now instead of thinking about it
specifically to cover states it's more
like
we are kind of indexing all the
behavioral patterns that we might want
to execute
i think these are both very exciting you
know directions for trying to
use up learn the options for this type
of exploration
but they all have kind of a a
significant difficulty
which is that you have to learn them and
that cause that costs a lot right so to
actually learn these effectively
uh and and then for them to be so
effective once
learned that that they're going to
overcome whatever
additional sample complexity it took you
to get to the point where they're useful
can be really hard um and that's why
later on we'll we'll be talking about
this heuristic set
but another really promising approach
and i only
is to meta learn this set of options on
a series of related domains
um and i only give one example and maybe
a little older of an example here
mainly because the previous talk is
already covering so many different
options
uh meta learning methods um and i think
this has a lot of promise
by not paying that learning cost
all on the current domain but kind of
spreading it out over your previous
experiences with different domains you
you might not have the same
kind of penalty or uh cost as in the
first category
and then the third one which is really
where i guess i'll be spending most of
my time here
is you could just say here's a fixed set
of options
where you've essentially chosen some
heuristic to combine
your actions and this even has been done
previously in some form or another uh
it is also the type of uh exploration
procedure i'll be evaluating later on
and we call it easy greedy for the two
sampling distributions first your
epsilon probability of sampling to to
begin exploration
once you've chosen to explore your set
of options are just the action repeat
policies so you will choose an action
uniformly
and then repeatedly take that action for
some duration
sampled from a distribution z
so it is as simple as that sound so just
as an example almost a pseudo code
example right
probably epsilon sample a random action
uniformly and then
sample a duration and then follow that
action repeatedly
so why why does this even make sense at
all well
uh first there's we can kind of borrow
the theoretical
uh some of the theoretical guarantees of
epsilon greedy uh
because as long as there's support on uh
a one-step
duration then we kind of have those same
uh primitive action exploration
guarantees um
on the other hand the inductive bias
that this is um
encoding is that if i repeatedly take an
action
it is going to lead me to or it's going
to correspond to a type of shortest path
on the mdp
another way of thinking about this is if
the actions have very consistent effects
throughout the state space
then this is an exploration of this
that's going to perform
fairly well but when those are violated
we shouldn't expect it to perform well
at all
so to give two examples of that i'm
going to focus on
some extreme versions of that so the
first one
is an extreme version of not aligning
with that particular inductive bias
and that's deep c uh part of the b suite
um
so let's consider one uh experience
within
uh deep sea so we sample an environment
and
here we have the actions a0 and a1
corresponding to going
to the right and going down into the
left
in this case because the action effects
are consistent throughout all of the
states
to actually reach the goal it becomes
very very simple with something like
easy greeting we sample
the option repeat the action repeat
option that goes to the right
as long as the duration is long enough
to get there we're going to get there in
one decision
so this is going to be very easy and we
think we're on
on a roll to solve deep sea uh
but the next seed where you try to train
the same
method again has all of the action
effects randomly per
muted so now x0 instead of a
uh instead of a0 going left a0 goes
right
and in x2 a0 goes
left again a1 goes right so the meaning
of left and right has been completely
randomized in a state dependent way
so while this purple option led us
directly to the goal before
and now leads us to this very
uninteresting random state
somewhere that isn't rewarding so this
is an example where
the action effects are kind of maximally
inconsistent
and we shouldn't expect something like
easy greedy to do well
in fact you would need to within that
one
environment that instance of of the
deepsea need to be learning your options
in there it also it might not even work
with a meta learning
one but we can talk about that maybe so
let's look at some examples where it's
more uplifting news
let's think about that uh standard chain
mdp
where now going right consistently
eventually leads you to the goal
whereas anytime you take the left action
you reset back
to the starting state now
uh kind of as before you you sample an
option
and you can by sampling these options
and durations you actually
index into all of the reachable states
and that makes the
exploration extremely efficient um
okay a final example now we have a open
continuous grid world where your action
space
are any of the points on the on the
circle so you can take an action that
goes in any direction
continuously well here again we have uh
you know this is going to be a good news
type of situation because
i can now index into reaching any of my
reachable states
by sampling some direction that
corresponds to going towards that state
and a duration that's long enough to
pass through it
and i bring up this last example in part
because it allows us to talk about a
little
diversion which is there it is the
precise same uh abstraction
that ecologists use as a model of animal
foraging
and to model that animal forging they
use a method often not always called
levy flights and levy flights and easy
greedy in this particular setting
are identical if you set that sampling
distribution
to the zeta distribution which is
parameterized by this new value
which essentially tells us how we should
concentrate towards
uh one or towards infinity so as
mu goes to one it looks more like a
uniform distribution of durations
and as mu goes to three it looks more uh
exponentialish
that's uh anyway uh one of the really
interesting things here though
is that the ecologists research have
found that there is actually an in this
simplified abstraction
an optimal value of mu and this is
because it's trading off two
uh requirements for forging and i think
also for exploration
which is the need to visit many states
to maximize your
coverage and not repeatedly see the same
states
and the desire to see rewards or in that
their case
food that is easy to get to nearby and
and these two
trade off to allow there to exist a
maximal value
now this is also the value that best
fits the
the animal forging data and this is just
a
cherry there's no actual like
interesting claim here but when we swept
over mu
in our easy greedy experiments we
actually found a very similar type of
optimization
with mu 2.0 being essentially the best
value so that's what we use
throughout for all of our experiments
i said we should really be evaluating on
many domains and also with many
algorithms and
that's what we did but for limited time
i'm going to focus on just a couple
um so in mountain car right for those
not
immediately rep this is not immediately
available
mountain car is this underpowered car in
a valley the goal is at the
other end of the mountain and you need
to kind of build up some momentum
so that you can you know coast into that
goal but you can't go directly there so
it's interesting
because although the action effects are
somewhat consistent generally you know
accelerating or reversing
does have the corresponding effects on
the x position
but they are not entirely consistent so
it's a little bit of a soft violation of
that assumption
where as you go up the mountain the the
more you accelerate there's less and
less there's a diminishing returns
effect and eventually you'll slide back
so this is what happens when you do
completely uniform random exploration in
the action space
and we're looking at the time to first
visit in expectation over many many
trials
and what's interesting and we've bend it
its continuous state uh
problem and the goal is here and what
happens is that without any other
process uniform exploration doesn't see
the goal
frequently enough to even register in
this in this particular experiment it's
extremely unlikely to see it
which is why often mountain car might
have a per step negative cost
but in these experiments we're only
looking at the sparse reward version so
zero award until you get to the goal by
comparison
easy greedy is regularly generating that
that goal state and i and that's what
allows it to learn very effectively on
this problem
i should mention this is a linear
function approximation with a fourier
basis
and doing q lambda uh because you know q
learning and
linear function approximation um okay
so now we're going to turn to the larger
scale experiments which is going to be
atari 57 experiments and i said
different
you know this algorithm should work well
on different kind of base learners and
different agent architectures so we're
going to consider
two first we'll look at rainbow which
has lots of bells and whistles
but is only trained for 200 million
frames um
and then we'll look at r2d2 which is a
distributed training
framework with slightly fewer whistles
than rainbow
uh in rainbow we're also comparing
against two additional things
rainbow only has exploration through
noisy nets
and so as a starting point we actually
added epsilon greedy and surprisingly
found just adding up still ingredient on
the rainbow
already gives you quite a significant
improvement in performance
overall but at the cost of slightly
worse performance on the hardest games
we also compare against an intrinsic
motivation
based uh on pseudocounts using the cts
density model
and these results look maybe
really good for easy greedy and a bit uh
pessimistic
for for pseudo counts but if we dig into
the per game
results we see pseudo counts is doing
exactly what it was meant to do it it
does very well on monsoon's revenge
private eye and venture
and we see that easy greedy is improving
exploration of those problems sometimes
as much as as sue accounts
but but not nearly as much in particular
in montezuma
what's happening what causes these plots
on these two
is that it that improvement on montezuma
comes at the cost
on almost every other game so
a very similar story unfolds for r2d2
here we're comparing uh different
variant like r2d2 with different types
of exploration so r2d2 with epsilon
greedy
r2d2 with intrinsic motivation based on
random network distillation
and a bootstrap dqm version of r2d2
that is based on learning and ensemble
action values
and sampling those per episode to follow
that policy
um so here we have a nice kind of third
player here because
r d looks a lot like what we saw in
pseudocounts previously where it really
had is hurting performance
over the whole suite and the the
improvement on let's say montezuma isn't
even enough
to like show up in this human gap which
is
looking at how well it does relative to
superhuman performance
so that really this is the error
remaining before we get to
superhuman on all the games whereas easy
greedy is not only not
hurting performance it's actually
improving it over the rest of the
suite but i think we get a better
picture of these things by looking at
the per game results
what's happening here is that r d gives
us
wonderful performance on montezuma's
revenge but at a terrible cost
for a variety of other environments like
breakout
and tennis where it's really hurting
performance
that said i would say both bootstrap and
uh
easy greedy are doing something of a of
a
of a trade-off here right there they're
both improving
performance on the hard exploration
games montezuma's revenge and private
eye
while not hurting too much or even
improving
in some of the other games and this is
the the key kind of takeaway that
this surprisingly simple heuristic is
is actually improving performance fairly
broadly uh but in particular
doing that without uh hurting some of
these dense reward settings
so excuse me bill yeah can we uh
wrap up in about maybe less than a
minute yes
thanks sorry about that um i i'll just
say that there
there are lots of limitations that are
fairly obvious that i
brought up a little bit before um and
that the future directions would really
be focused on taking some of those
existing words for learning options and
combining with them with this
style of exploration with those options
we actually tried to scale up such a
method and it's just
very hard to overcome that kind of
learning cost when you go to large-scale
environments
um thank you everyone
okay thanks well this is excellent um
we have a few minutes uh before we uh
for questions before we
take the break any questions from the
panelists or
attendees
let's see yeah there is a question
from attendees i'm not sure where we can
see it uh could this really work on
more complex environments like delta ii
or starcraft
yeah that's that's a great point so
um i think that one of the
things for both of those is the question
of whether or not like
repeatedly taking the same action makes
sense
in in any kind of useful way there um i
think in talking to some of the people
who worked on starcraft
there are instances of this uh where
this type of repetition actually makes a
lot of sense because the primitive
actions end up being like
build this unit um and you might want to
repeatedly build this unit but
it's not clear that those are going to
be especially
well aligned with this type of uh the
easy greedy version of exploration
i think for those it makes a lot more
sense to learn
options relevant to those those special
domains
so uh i guess i was wondering and this
may be taking it
to a bit of an extreme but if i
if i were to go off this intuition then
maybe
uh the right thing to do rather than
think of this
as a different exploration strategy is
to say that well we're just using
the wrong duration for a sticky action
in atari and we should just like modify
it to be much much longer and that's
that's that right because as far as i
understand
uh the the len the duration of the
option is not kind of being adaptively
uh tuned in any manner during the
execution
and yeah how do you think about that
um i think that's very reasonable
um if you think about the your when you
say sticky action i'm think not sure
whether we're thinking of
action repeats that that as far as i
know all the atari
uh environments implement or or the
specific sticky action that uh
mark and marloes for instance have have
proposed in the ale
um in the case of action repeats
as a like a primitive that's very very
problematic we've done some experiments
where we
we actually consider different action
repeats across the atari suite and
you know four is a nice uh is most
commonly used it's a nice number
for getting the best overall performance
you can definitely improve
individual games by increasing that
significantly
but there ends up being a cost on the
other game so
not for a fixed one we can't just push
that up arbitrarily
but from just a general exploration
let's like let this stickiness be kind
of heavy-tailed in its
behavior that is essentially what's
going on here and it would
it seems to be said uh it seems like it
would just generally improve atari
performance yes um
does that hopefully answer that question
yep i want to jump
in well if i can and from a sort of a
technical perspective
and this is actually a related alex
question about uh
action repeats um it seems to me
like what this approach is saying is we
don't really know
how long we should quote unquote hold an
action for right
and that's really an artifact from
discretizing time so i want
i want to ask have you thought about the
usefulness
or the necessity of this approach in a
continuous time
regime where you have to explore but
that you know time is truly continuous
yeah i can't say that i've thought
significantly about it
um there is a lot of so i i reference
these these levy flight type of
ecological models
uh and in those areas which are mainly
focused on the theory
they they actually there's a lot of
discussion about whether you're doing
a uh a flight measured in terms of kind
of
time or in distance uh and these lead to
somewhat different uh models so
in that sort of case of a continuous
time you would probably
want to revert to measuring it in terms
of distance and you're aiming to move a
certain distance in
a direction or or follow this policy for
you know a change in distance in some
latent space
more questions uh yeah maybe i'll ask a
question um
yeah really interesting work well um it
seems like
one of the themes in your talk was that
um some of the exploration methods that
we have maybe are overfit the particular
domains
um and so i guess it's kind of a
takeaway that some of the progress that
we think we've made is a little bit
illusory in that sense
yeah um yeah i really don't
want to over emphasize but like yeah i
think so
like it seems like we've solved a lot of
these games perhaps especially
montezuma's revenge
and this might be more of a
we solve that one it won't necessarily
transfer uh broadly and we can
maybe even see that with just how
infrequently these more complex
exploration methods
end up getting used uh outside of the
original work that that proposed them
thanks by the way for the question
well um i maybe i can ask a quick
question uh
as well um uh emma and i had a while ago
at a paper that talks about exploration
with
options or temporary extended actions um
then we found that there is a trade-off
between
a number of options or demand or options
on these kind of quantities
the analysis in the paper is for tableau
rl
but i wonder if some of these things
some of these trade-offs may also hold
or in dprl
have you observed that empirically
so so uh i can't say that we've observed
it
empirically uh mainly because these kind
of uh experiments are
are so focused on these like action
repeats
um and when we were doing some of those
experiments i kind of
briefly passed over it was kind of a
continuous space of of
but i think analytically there is there
is a real
reason to to worry about just
arbitrarily expanding our set
of options because to think about like
okay we want to ensure that we
are increasing the the visitation rate
of some of these under visited states by
a particular behavior and some option
that
that probability is going to immediately
be scaled by the the magnet the how big
that
that set of options is and if you just
orbit it you could wash out your hope
of sampling the right option to get you
where you need to go
so that i think is a is a very real
issue uh
so yeah
thank you thank you
okay so maybe um we can start
to take the break and then uh if there
are more questions for the speakers we
can
we have a 30 minutes discussion session
um
later of the day um so let's uh return
by we'll return at 11 uh 11 a.m berkeley
time
which is um 2 p.m new york or sometime
london sorry i can't do that
okay thanks everyone